it is giving day here at channel 8 and
today we are proud to team up with red
cross to host a blood drive
our very own john langler and nate
tannenbaum live at the sahara west
library now with
more on that hello you two good to see
you
hey alex it's great to see you john here
we are at the sahara west library the
blood drive just got underway and we've
already had some folks donating that's
right they're gonna we're gonna be until
4
30 for this blood drive donations are
really needed because the pandemic a lot
of drives were
postponed or canceled if you want to
come here though you have to make an
appointment first go to
redcrossblood.org
or call 1-800-733-2767
this is a fellow who has actually been
only donating
since the pandemic this is wayne
peterson wayne tell us why you started
to donate blood
i just wanted to do something positive
make a contribution
uh since the pandemic started it seemed
like i needed to do something
and here you are yeah just donated again
this is the sixth time in the last year
for someone who's never donated blood
it's not that big a deal
it really isn't uh might feel just a
small
pin prick but it's really easy to do you
get snacks
and water free water all right wayne
thank you so much and thanks for being
part of the blood drive
uh so john we're going to be back here a
little bit later in the newscast and we
have a special guest coming up
after a special guest coming up in about
10 minutes or so again if you can donate
blood do what you can make a reservation
online and try and help out the red
cross here the sahara west library
back to you thank you both so much we'll
see in a few minutes and
we're nate and john r it's the that
library it's on fort apache and sahara
if you would like to go
thank you guys we'll see in a bit